in the summer of 2019 a bull was found
dead on a farm in North Carolina dead by
exsanguination which means it was
drained of blood
the culprit wasn't real life vampires
but something just as frightening an
army of more than a thousand Asian
long-horned ticks but here's the thing
as scary as that sounds
Asian Longhorns are just one of about
ninety tick species found in the u.s.
all of them suck blood all of them can
carry disease and all of them are
incredibly difficult to kill
[Music]
the Asian long-horned tick is truly a
villainous pest not only is it an
invasive species but it can also clone
itself over and over again since it was
first reported in 2017 it scrawled its
way to at least 12 other states
including where we are here New York
okay so this is an adult this looks like
the Asian long-horned ticks to me this
is the yeah that's Daniel Tufts a
disease ecologist at Columbia University
she's studying ticks in Staten Island to
figure out what diseases they carry but
first she has to collect them so this is
what we call a drag cloth and it's a
meter by meter so a meter squared and
basically what we do is we just walk at
a nice even slow pace and drag this
right behind us and we'll stop every
about 20 meters or so and we'll flip the
cloth over and we'll look for whatever
ticks are on the back side contrary to
what many people believe ticks don't
actively seek you out so here's a tick
right here this is a very tikki forest
and they're definitely not jumping on
you from trees in fact ticks can't even
jump they're actually more like
opportunists who take what they can get
tics are what we call sit and wait
predators they climb up to the top of
the blades of grass and they put their
their arms out and they're at the top of
their arms they have little kind of
sticky pads and those pads will get
attracted to this and this is how they
get stuck on your pants or on other
animals in the wild as well and what do
you call the like when they stick their
hands up like this
we call that questing or host seeking
yeah
ticks are literally on a quest for blood
and they've mastered the art of
extracting it all without getting caught
after a tick crawls on to you it sneaks
into a concealed crevice like your
armpit and after that it uses two
horrifying hook like structures to tear
into your flesh and keep from falling
off
then they insert what is basically a
straw covered in spikes like a piece of
barbed wire which makes them even harder
to remove and this sounds like it would
hurt a lot but tics have another trick
up their sleeve or rather their mouths
saliva
it's a ticks ultimate weapon to avoid
detection
it contains pain numbing properties so
you don't notice them even as they stab
and rip your flesh plus it suppresses
your immune system so the wound is less
likely to get red or itchy
that's why ticks can stay in you
undetected for days even as they grow to
several times their normal size and if
you do find a tick in time to get it off
it won't die easily tuff says that ticks
can survive for as long as two years
without a blood meal and they're also
masters of the elements they can
tolerate long periods of drought and
some species can survive underwater for
two to three days so yeah flushing them
down the toilet or sink likely won't
kill them you put them in the sink
sometimes they'll crawl back out of the
sink now all of this wouldn't be such a
big problem if it weren't for the
diseases they carry in the US alone they
transmit at least 16 diseases to humans
that's more than any other insect
including mosquitos Lyme disease alone
for example infects an estimated 300,000
Americans each year and it's only
getting worse in 2004 there are about
23,000 cases of tick-borne disease
report to the CDC but by 2017 that
number had almost tripled to nearly
60,000
but what isn't clear is why why ticks
and the diseases they carry are
spreading though Tufts and other
scientists say that climate change is at
least partly to blame we've been having
pretty mild winters which can promote
survival overwintering survival of hosts
and of the vectors which also will lead
to new expansion whatever the reason
there are tons of ticks pretty much
everywhere so the next time you go for a
hike keep these tips in mind stay on the
trails where ticks are less likely to
hang out where bug spray preferably
something with deep tuck your pants into
your socks so nothing can crawl into
your legs wear light clothes so anything
that does get on you is easy to spot and
of course always do a tick check once
you're out of the woods all right so
we're gonna do a tick check which you
recommend doing out after you go to the
woods
so crevices what you want to look for is
on your pants I wear rubber boots so
that they don't crawl up there but like
for here my my pants any of these little
crevices along here I would look for I
mean I feel like those those little guys
are definitely like the larval larvae
for more definitely on me right
somewhere maybe maybe not and then you
want to check up around the your your
belt region it's also good when you are
hiking with a friend to check each other
so for instance I would check your back
yes yeah grooming behavior so you want
to check all along the sleeves on
anywhere on the back so really like claw
on top of clothing like you don't need
to like strip down no no you can strip
down later in the shower
great
[Music]